hello YouTube chest lowers in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
last and the final part of my chest
syrota against efore
in this section we are going to see how
to deal the sidelines against the move
Knight to c6 and you can see they're
plenty now there are few points I like
to mention before we go and look at them
the first most obvious point is this
sidelines will be played by opponent
which is probably the weaker than you or
a person who doesn't know how to react
against nc6 more
the second most important point is
against the mainline stuff with start
with the move d4 or Knight to f3 white
obtained a slight advantage and black
needs to first of all equalize and then
look forward for the initiative well
here when your opponent plays the
sidelines moves black can equalize very
very easily and later stage you can
always look forward for getting
advantage in the middle game and the
third and the final important point I
like to mention is it's very hard to
give you exact mode so what I'm going to
do in this section is I am going to show
you ideas which black can look out and
the themes so you can walk on this and
you will obtain a good advantage
straight away in the opening so
considering all this let's get started
now specifically in this video I am
going to concentrate only moves on
Bishop to c4 and Bishop to b5 so first
of all we are going to see the move
Bishop to c4
against Bishop to c4 the first move we
are going to play is Knight to f6
pitting the e4 pawn so now there are two
replies is why can claim there will be a
transposition so it doesn't matter let's
say right here continue with the move
Knight to c3 and what white is hoping is
black is playing the movie fire so now
white can relax and become confident
because black enter into his familiar
territory but we are not going to do
that what we are going to do is instead
of the move ePHI we are going to play
the movie 6 and we are going to play the
quick defile this is you should always
remember in the Bishop to c4 line never
play e5 play a six and go for the quick
defy with already a slight advantageous
position I will show you two games in
this line in the first game my opponent
played the move d3 and I replied with
the Moody file now there are two obvious
replies from the white the first obvious
reply is ecaps is defy and after ecaps
is defy white plays the obvious looking
move Bishop to b3
here I propose that blacks should play
the move Bishop to be full and pinning
that night so now black has created the
first threat of pushing the d4 pawn in
this game I upon I responded with the
move Bishop to d2 I castle on the Kings
side so now I'm threatening the move
rook to e8 so my opponent blocked the
e-file with the move Knight G - E - I
played rook to e8 anyways and now he
castle on the Kings side it's time to
develop my last minor piece so I played
Bishop to g4 let this move I created
second thread that is I want to capture
the c3 Knight and then capturing the e2
Knight so why it needs to be very very
careful
my opponent responded with the move f3
getting out of the pin and hitting the
bishop here I give him this check and
after a king - h1 I played the move
Bishop to e6
my opponent responded with the Moon
Knight to f4 which is very nature
because he want to get that Bishop pair
but as soon as that night has been moved
I played the Moon Knight to d4
let's see what is the idea behind night
to d4 my opponent captured the bishop I
capture with the rook and now he played
the move rook - even
and now comes the whole idea of day six
move what I have done is first of all I
capture that roof and when why do we
capture I played the MU c6 and what it
does is it completely shut down this
bishop and the night and this is more or
less the theme of this e six move
what you need to do is on the right time
you need to move that night out and then
completely block it this Bishop the
spawn Chell so it will be very hard for
the white to you know activate this
Bishop so it will take a long time and
in the meantime you can activate your
major piece and develop an attack so
we'll see how I achieve in this game
after realizing what happens to his
Bishop my opponent responded with the
move Knight to a4
so he wants to probably now take the
bishop and play the move c3
I played the move Bishop to b6 and my
opponent responded with the move Bishop
to f2 I responded with the move Knight
to e6 so I'm giving no chance to him to
free of his Bishop hear my opponent
responded with the move Queen to e2
I played the move B Phi so drive is
Knight back to the c3 and now another
attacking a for more space on the Queen
side my opponent has to forcefully play
the move a 3 so a 4 comes anyways a
sharp drop backs to the a2 and now comes
Queen to e5 so I'm just trying with my
opponent I haven't responded with the
move Bishop to even and I played the
move Queen to c7 so now attacking the h2
which my opponent defended with the move
s3 but s3 created a hole on the g3 which
I immediately exploited with the move
Knight to edge file
right now Knight to g3 is not a big
threat but sooner or later I'm going to
create some tactics based on that square
here my opponent played the move Knight
to d1 so he was probably thinking of the
move c4 and liber8 that bishop but it's
too little too late because after the
move Knight to d4 my opponent realized
that he is in a big big danger I think
he was in the time trouble at this point
and he played the disasterous move that
is Queen to f2 and now I give you a few
seconds can you find the right
continuation which more or less finished
the right off
I hope you find this mu that is Knight
to g3 check and after King to Jeevan
this amazing new night we do just almost
a checkmate
except that white needs to grow up the
Queen and look at that pathetic pressure
which was in the prison by this amazing
pawn chain so this is the main concept
in the Bishop to c4 line
what black wants to do is to play the
movie six and quick d-file gaining
advantage quickly in the opening
now at this point the second move white
can't rise Bishop to b5 against this I'm
recommending that you should play the
move Bishop to d7 and hear my opponent
which was a higher rated one he played
the move Knight to f3 I responded with
the move a six so clarification of the
pin my opponent responded with the move
Bishop capture c6 and after I recaptured
he played the move Knight to e5 so he
just want to simplify the whole position
here I spun it with the move Queen to d6
my opponent captured the bishop I
recapture with the Queen and now he
played the move Queen to were three
so he's pressurizing the d5 pawn I
simply refuse everything with the move
Bishop to b4 so now there's a double pin
on the knight here white cannot catch
the d5 pawn if he would have captured
the d5 pawn then after Bishop to c3
white cannot capture the piece because
at the end
White will lose a room so what has to
play move such as King to have fun after
this
like and simply capture the d5 pawn with
the night and after B capture c3 and
Queen capture c3 there is an attack on
the roof so rook has to move and that
will capture the c2 fall once again
attacking the rook after rook - even
there is no need to go further you can
already see Black has a huge advantage
so that's why at this point my opponent
responded with the move Bishop to d2 but
after this the task become very very
easy for me
so what I did is first of all capture
the night and when white recapture with
the bishop I capture the pawn of course
black is not going to be a pawn up
because after few transactions white
will regain the pawn back Wiremu Bishop
captures g7 but what it does is it will
give an initiative to the black here I
responded with the move group to g8 and
after Bishop to e5 I Castle on the Queen
side so you can easily see black is
getting a huge initiative hear my
opponent responded with the move
castling on the King side and I
responded with the move f5 the simple
reason is I want to free up my Queen
which was tied up to defend that night
my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to g3
and I start my kingside attacked with
the mu H file my opponent is pointed
with the MU rook to d1 so he wants to
swap up the rooks but this mu turns out
as a blunder because now I captured the
room and in order to save the seat upon
my opponent has to recapture with the
Queen which allowed me to walk some good
tactics now before we look at them I
want you to pause the video and find out
the winning continuation for the black
I hope you find this move that is h4
now doesn't matter bishop capture the
phone or move somewhere for example in
this game my opponent capture the ball
but after this can you see it yep is
Knight to c3 not only black is
threatening to checkmate white on the g2
but that is also attacking the Queen and
white cannot parry both of them so my
opponent at this point reside
so with these two model games you can
have a good idea how to play against the
move Bishop to c4 it's time to look at
the next move that is Bishop could be
fire
bishop to be fire has been tried not
only by the beginners but even the
higher ranked players black should be
jolly delight because the line against
this will be a very simple and it will
give you a great advantage here black
should immediately hit this bishop with
the move a six and white has two choices
if white plays the normal move that is
Bishop to e4 then black can immediately
play the move B Phi and after the move
Bishop to b3 can you guessed it yep it's
the same concept what we are going to do
is first of all hit the e4 pawn with the
move Knight to f6 and whether white
plays the move d3 or Knight to c3 let's
say in this game my opponent responded
with the move d3 now comes the similar
formation which we already look at in
the Bishop to c4 line and that start
with the move e 6 at this point my
opponent is pointed with the move Knight
to c3
there is no price for guessing you can
already see the defy is coming after he
captures be fine he captures defy once
again you can see what kind of theme is
cropping up
seeing this danger my opponent responded
with the move Bishop to P Phi so his
idea is very simple he wants to capture
the night and then capture the defy pawn
well I responded with the move Bishop to
b5 setting up the tactics he fall for it
I can't say it's fall for it but it's
just an initial move so my opponent
responded with the move Bishop captures
night and after Queen captures he
grabbed the d5 pawn and in fact he has
to because if he play at a passive move
such as Knight g - e - then after d4
white we lose a piece because a3 counter
doesn't create any threat black can
simply drop the bishop back to the a5
and now that Knight is a goner
so that's why my opponent has to
forcefully capture this d5 pawn
and after this I capture the night my
opponent recaptured the bishop and now I
capture the c-3po so now not only am
saving my c6 Knight but I am preventing
why to play the move Queen to d2 my
opponent has to obviously play moves
such as King to have fun and after this
I just castle on the Kings side
he continued with the Moon Knight to e2
hitting the Queen
I place my queen on the c5 square
hitting the bishop so you played Bishop
to f3 and I responded with the moog -
yet my opponent decided to give his King
some air so he played the MU g3 but
after Bishop check he decided to block
the check with the Bishop I exchanged
the bishops and played the move Knight
to e5 at this point white needs to be
very very careful and I have seen many
games where my opponent rush to this
move that is rook - even so what white
wants to do is get the rug out of the
jail and then place the King back to the
g1 but in this position it will be a too
dangerous because now black can't finish
of the white
I give you a few seconds can you find a
continuation which will more or less win
the game
okay I hope you find this continuation
let's start with the move Queen to c6
check
now King to h3 will be very very
dangerous and you can't think of the
move King to g1 so the only move left is
king to f1 so my opponents idea is to if
I'm giving the check then he can block
the check with the night but now comes
the second ogre to move that is Knight
to g4 so now the planning is very simple
once again the Queen check but this time
if white defense with the night then
Knight to edge 2 will be actually a
checkmate so my opponent has to
forcefully play the move King to g1 and
now come the final blow which is green
to f3 so now once again threatening the
move such as Queen captures f2 and Queen
captures edge to checkmate
so my opponent has to save the mate with
the only move that is rooked where fun
but this move allow me to capture the
whole piece that is ro captures eat so
not only black has capture of piece but
there is a tag to boot
and after this move you can guess my
opponent immediately resigned so I hope
this game will give you enough
information how you should respond
against the move Bishop to e4 you can
always go for the quick b5 and then e 6
and d5 and if you open and try to do
some cheap tactics with the move Bishop
to g5 from this game you have the enough
idea how to handle those techniques
after the move a six white can go for
the second line that is Bishop capture
c6 and when black recaptured with the
b-pawn white grab the center with the
move d4 against this I am recommending
that you should immediately hit back in
the center with the move D file and
there are two ways white can respond it
in the first game my opponent responded
with the move Knight to c3 after this I
responded with the move e 6 and now here
is the plan what black is aiming for is
destroying the white center with to see
points so you have a structure like
French order caro-kann but it's a
superior one because Y doesn't have the
light square bishop to attack black on
the Kings side let's see how this all
walk out in the practical game hear my
opponent responded with the move Knight
to f3 I responded with the move Knight
to f6 and he responded with the move
Bishop to g5 so creating a pin I break
the pin with the move Bishop to e7 and
now this sort of moves which you're
always going to expect that is the move
e5 and this is actually we won't because
now we are going to play the move Knight
to d7 my opponent captured his Bishop
I'd recapture with the Queen and he
castle on the Kings side and the move
which was waiting for awhile
yup it's a c5 destroying the white
center
seeing no good way to defend the d4 pawn
my opponent decided to capture the c5
pawn I recaptured with the knight and
now he plays the move Queen tweet I
castle on the Kings side and he
responded with the move rook to d1 so in
a way white is playing just initial
moves but white is planned less in this
kind of scenario and that is the big
advantage black is getting black plan is
very simple what black wants to do is to
expand on the Queen side and attack
white they're after Queen to e2 I
responded with the move Bishop to b7 my
opponent responded with the move b4
I dropped my knight back to the d7 and
this is what happened when you are plan
less this kind of errors will occur and
my opponent played the move B Phi which
is which stands out as a big mistake
before we go and look what mistake my
opponent has done I want you to pause
the video and find out why this move is
wrong
okay I hope you find this solution that
is
capturing the pawn now doesn't matter
how white recaptured in the game my
opponent responded with the move Knight
captures b5
but after the move c6 the game is over
let's see what happened if white plays
the move Knight to d6 well it's very
simple
black will skewer the Queen and rook and
black emerge with an exchange op
in the game my opponent decided to play
the move Knight to d4
but our tactics will remain as it is
because I played the move Bishop to e6
my opponent's idea was to capture the c6
pawn and counter-attack the black queen
but after Queen to c5
the threat remain as it is so white is
forced to move the Queen might play the
move Queen to e3 but after Queen
captures Knight black is clearly in the
driving seat with a piece of situation
so that is about Knight to c3 at this
position instead of Knight to c3 it is
possible that your opponent can play the
move immediate ePHI against this you can
use the similar setup which have shown
in my previous game but if you are a
very ambitious player you can try this
aggressive move that is Bishop to a5
however personally this is bit risky so
if you are trying it just try it against
a low-rated play Bishop 2fi has a very
simple idea what black wants to do is
let's say after the move Knight to f3
black will play the movie 6 and you can
see that Bishop is outside the pawn
chain
so it's an active piece I then sitting
on the CH in this game I happen
responded with the MU Castle and I
responded with the mu C file so
immediate C file in this game
my opponent responded with the move C 3
so now there is a threat of Queen to a4
check and this is a drawback of this
bishop to highlight however you will see
in this game I can easily deal dealt
with this so I played the move Queen to
d7 my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to e3 I capture the pawn he
recaptured when I played the move Knight
to e7
my opponent developed his last minor
piece with the move Knight to c3 and I
played the move Bishop to g6 so what I
want to do is to play the move Knight to
f5 develop a bishop and then castle on
the Kings side here a my opponent
responded with the move Knight to a4 so
his idea is to prong the light on the C
file I invite him to do that so I played
the move Knight to a5 and he attacked my
queen with the move Knight of C file
such a nonsense should be immediately
removed so I captured the night and
after white recapture I captured the
bishop
when white captured back the piece you
can already see positionally it's a
winning game for the black because white
pawns are all over the place and gain
continuation will show you how to
execute such a plan so here I first of
all hit the b2 pawn with the move rook
to BH my opponent responded with the
move b3 and I hit this loose c5 on with
the move rook to be fire
my opponent defended with the move Queen
to d4 so the queen is acting like a
sophisticated pawn i castle on the Kings
side my opponent responded with the move
p4 so protecting the c5 pawn I responded
with the move rook to b8 so you can see
how easy it is for black to place such a
position but it's very difficult for
white to you know hold on to this
position and defending everything
my opponent responded with the move a3
and now comes the e4 and white allowed
to play the move rook to be won but
right now that bishop is not allowing to
do that and that means that b4 pawn will
be definitely gone after a long thinking
my opponent played the move Knight to e4
but I preserve my bishop with the move
Bishop to e4 and he comes back with his
Knight
so you can already see he's a plot less
I captured the pawn white recapture and
now I clear any threads of white with
the MU at six
my opponent thought that I give him time
to defend the b4 pawn so he played the
move rook to e4 but after one move
Bishop to c2 he realized that he cannot
save the v4 born after the game
continuation rook to a2 I captured the
b-pawn with the attack on the Queen my
opponent played the move Queen to c3
but that allow me to activate my piece
more freely with the move rook to c4
desperate for counter play my opponent
responded with the move Queen to e5 and
I responded with the move Bishop to b4
so once again centralizing the bishop
which is always going to be useful that
piece is so strong that my opponent
decided to eliminate that piece with the
move Knight to d2 I responded with the
move rook to b4 and now he removed that
Bishop with the move Knight captures I
recapture with the rook my opponent
decided to save the e3 pawn with the
move rook to a3 I can eat that epon
anytime so i activate my queen with the
move Queen to e7 and after rook to a1 i
activate my final piece with the move
rook to pay to
and locate the pathetic position of
white why three major PCs are on the a
file but I don't understand what is
trying to do with those meanwhile Black
has activated both his rook and Queen is
also coming on the kingside and it's a
disasterous position for white and still
my opponent go for it so he played the
Queen to a a check I played King to
eight seven and now he played rook to a2
so he wants to eliminate that active
rook after a few calculation I capture
that rook and when white recapture with
the rope I simply grab the c4 pawn and
at this point you can understand the
reaction of my apology to hopeless pawns
in the center with unsafe King my
opponent has given up at this point
so with this game I have shown you two
ideas one with the bishop outside the
pawn chain and the second one without it
and in both the condition what black is
aiming for is a French or the caro-kann
structure with a good hit in the center
with the MU C Phi well thank you for
watching this lecture feel free to
comment and like it and I will meet you
in my next lecture very soon bye